bonjour à toutes et à tous il y a des
gens qui pensent que quelque part dans
la jungle au congo survie un dinosaure
qu'ils appellent le mokélé mbembé voici
5 bonnes raisons de ne pas croire aux
mokélé mbembé premièrement l'origine du
mythe
le mythe du mokélé mbembé a été décrit
originellement en rhodésie du nord
c'est-à-dire dans l'actuelle zambie et
en afrique du sud
or il n'y a pas des masses de jungle là
bas alors le mythe qu'est ce qu'il a
fait baisser déplacer ils là où il ya de
la jungle
parce que là où il ya de la jungle il ya
du mystère et c'est comme ça qu'on a
fini avec le récit du mokélé mbembé au
congo au lesotho par exemple il parle du
couloumé l'houmeau qui est aussi un
animal qui ressemblerait à un dinosaure
mais comme par hasard n'y a pas
d'histoire comme quoi il serait encore
vivant
pourquoi pas parce qu'à pas de jungle où
les autos tu m'écoutes ou quoi
deuxièmement l'épreuve entre guillemets
les témoignages sont tous
contradictoires il décrypte un animal
tantôt rampant carnivores et aquatiques
un crocodile un gros herbivores avec une
corne sur le nez un rhino ou bien énorme
animal herbivore avec un long cou une
longue queue est une énorme dans ou une
corne au bout de la tête mais tu peux
pas choisir que les détails anatomiques
tu t'arranges juste parce que tu veux
que ça ressemble à un diplodocus si tu
veux te baser sur des témoignages très
bien vas-y fais-le mais n'en garde pas
que la moitié sinon moi je prends que la
moitié qui m'intéresse un épi jeudi que
le mokélé mbembé passait une licorne les
photos elles sont toutes loubet sinon il
y aurait plus de mystères et les
empreintes de mokélé mbembé qui ont été
trouvés ah bah ça c'est intéressant
elles ont trois doigts alors ok c'est
pas un éléphant c'est pas un hippopotame
non plus mais du coup ça qualifie pas
non plus très bien pour le dip le cul ça
parce que voici les pattes d'un
sauropode standard vous voyez trois
doigts ou vous hein
par contre maintenant je vous mets
l'empreinte de panat rhinocéros
troisième bonne raison de ne pas croire
aux mokélé mbembé tu crois vraiment que
les paléontologues ne s'intéresserait
pas un vrai dinosaures vivants s'il n'y
avait pas une bonne raison d'en douter
s'il y avait ne serait-ce que la micro
ombres d'une petite chance qu'il existe
le mokélé mbembé mais ça ferait
longtemps qu'on l'aurait rasé à coups de
marteau de géologues la jungle et était
histoires de complots créationnistes du
genre bah oui les paléontologues il
cherche à cacher l'existence des
dinosaures parce que ça remettrait la
théorie de l'évolution en douter
à niamey c'est n'importe nawak pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'on connaît
déjà des tonnes de soi disant fossiles
vivants et que pour autant que je sache
la théorie de l'évolution elle s'en
accommode très bien ça changerait
absolument rien de trouver un possible
bilan de plus rien du tout quatrième
raison parce que les indigènes ont
déclaré avoir reconnu que cet animal là
était à mokélé mbembé sauf que cet
animal là c'est pas à sauropodes c'est
l'idée qu'on se faisait des sauropodes
il y à 50 ans une bestiole énorme qui
vit dans l'eau et qui traîne une lourde
que c'est pas à ça tu ressemblais à
sauropodes
et vous savez comment on le sait rom non
on n'a pas besoin d'en avoir vu en vrai
non non non on le sait tout simplement
parce qu'on a des empreintes fossilisées
des empreintes de pas fait sur de la
terre ferme parfois même en milieu
désertique et sur lequel on voit
clairement aucune trace d'eux que donc
ce n'était pas des animaux semi
aquatique et il ne traînez pas leur que
derrière eux donc ce qu'ont reconnu les
indigènes sur les photos ça ne
correspond à rien et enfin cinquième et
dernière raison de ne pas croire mokélé
mbembé des histoires de monstres
il y en a partout dans toutes les
cultures tout autour du monde et on n'a
aucun mal à se dire qu'elles sont
imaginaires alors en vertu de quoi celle
là serait différente eh ben je vais vous
le dire moi en quoi elle est différente
c'est parce que des foutus
créationnistes veulent l'utiliser contre
la théorie de l'évolution
alors que ça sert à rien voir le petit
roi de cette vidéo n'est fossiles
vivants qui en est un de plus à moins on
s'en fout la théorie de l'évolution elle
tient très bien tout seul donc on sait
très bien pourquoi elles flottent dans
l'air et sur internet cette théorie du
bouc et les modems b c'est juste parce
que des créationnistes veulent vous
convaincre que la théorie de l'évolution
n'existe pas alors à les lier à la bonne
littérature sur le sujet le livre
abominable sayans le blog tétrapodes
zoologie et pour ceux qui font pas trop
dans l'anglais le bouquin d'eric
buffeteau voilà tous ont été écrits au
moins en partie par des paléontologues
et vous verrez qu'il y à bien des
spécialistes en dinosaure qui
s'intéressent au sujet avec sérieux et
sans l'ombre d'un complot merci à tous
et à une prochaine fois sur cette option